[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
World Cup starts on Sunday and we
thought Tab Ramos one of the greatest
soccer players we've ever produced would
be able to help us the head coach of
Hartford athletic and working for
Telemundo is their World Cup analyst and
he joins us on the program from Qatar
thanks for joining us tab uh set the
scene there of what you expect the World
Cup to be like over the next uh few few
days weeks
hi Dad thank you for having me on
um well I expect it to be extremely
competitive you know teams have been
getting closer to each other uh many of
them within their confederations had a
real tough time to get here uh
I think it'd be a tough competitive uh
tournament from the get-go
your favorites let's say top three
favorites are
uh tough uh top three would be Brazil
Argentina and France those are the teams
that likely have the most talent and the
ones that are most ready to potentially
win the tournament
give me your sneaky team or teams
sneaky team likely that no one is
talking about Denmark Denmark has the
talent uh Denmark had a great qualifying
round but is not one that people mention
when they talk about potential winners
or or or teams that could upset other
teams to get to finals such as could be
Portugal it could be Holland it could be
those teams I think I think Denmark
could be the Dark Horse if I haven't
seen the United States play
how would you describe them going into
this tournament
uh us is a team that's that's very
athletic it's Dynamic uh they have good
athletes fast uh they're good in
transition uh and now you know what they
have players who technically are are
very good this us team can can basically
compete against any team uh any team in
the world right now
we also look at youth uh differently
sometimes it's you're too young or
sometimes you're so young you don't know
any better and you just play differently
you got the United States I think the
youngest team in the world cup or
certainly one of the youngest how do
they use that to their advantage
yeah so here's the thing about the US
team so it's I it's the second youngest
team at the World Cup
um yet is is a team with a lot of
experience you know we have players who
play on on big clubs around the world
who are used to playing big games week
in and week out and although it's the
second youngest team here and likely the
youngest team we have ever had uh is
probably the most experienced team that
we have had
the one player on the United States that
as he goes the team will go is who
foreign
polisik you know Christian pulseek is
the star Christian positive will likely
be the captain of the team
um unfortunately Christian policich
hasn't really done well for the national
team over the last year and a half you
know there's been other guys that have
been pulling this team hard and I think
this is the time where the best player
on the team has to be the best player on
the team and that's Christian Paulson
all right give me the realistic
expectations there for Team USA
yeah realistic expectations would be
that you know when I match up player by
player uh the U.S Squad compared to the
whale Squad we are better when I match
up player by player us Squad versus Iran
we are better when I match us up against
England we're likely not so if we're
second in the group we shouldn't get
into the second round I think the
problem is that the US team has not done
much to give us the confidence that they
can really win those two games that
they're supposed to win I'm hoping that
they can turn it around that they're
ready to go that they're excited to show
their best because we have not seen
their best how would you describe cutter
uh it's it's fabulous it's unbelievable
I mean it's a country that's basically
you know the feeling when there's uh you
go and see a brand new house you go into
a new community and you're shopping for
a new house this is sort of what it's
like it's taken the keys to a brand new
house uh and Qatar is brand new
expensive though those houses though
oh there's no question you're buying in
a in a good part of town
the weather does weather play an issue
uh when the games are held
no I don't think it will I don't think
it will we have days here just about
every day the highest temperature is
about 92 93 degrees the lowest is about
75 to 70 somewhere in that range and
most of the games are played at night
USS all three games I believe at 10 p.m
starts which will put them in the in the
mid to low 70s uh at GameStop so I don't
think the weather will be an issue at
all when you were on Team USA the best
team you ever faced best player you ever
faced was who
well likely the best team we ever face
is probably Italy in 1990 when we had to
play them in Rome
um you know when it comes to the best
player
it's hard to pick because we played
against a lot of good players but I
would have to say maybe
Valderrama in 1994 he was at his best
and he was playing for a Columbia team
that was selected to be one of the
favorites for that World Cup uh and we
knocked them out when we beat him how
were the fans to you in Rome when you're
facing Italy
well look I mean we we had come you know
we're a bunch of young guys no
experience we we were basically tourists
and when we went to when we went to
Italy and uh we arrived after losing to
Czech Republic the first game 5-1 uh and
all we saw when we looked out of our bus
was fans going like this for you know
we're gonna beat you 10-0 uh so they
thought it was going to be an easy game
we managed to still he's only one zero
but for us that was pretty much like a
victory at the time how important is
that uh match against England
it's huge I think it's huge because I
think it it can it can sort of getting a
good result against England in that game
um it can put us at that place where we
can really dream about what this team
can do in this world cup
um I think we have the talent for it and
uh and I'm hoping that that England game
is a great game even if we even if we
were to lose that game by one goal if we
could see that up and down transition
game but we really match up against them
um that would give us a lot of
confidence going into a second round
Ted thank you uh have fun over there we
appreciate your time
thank you for having me on that's uh Tab
Ramos he's uh looks like he's on a
balcony there in a high-rise overlooking
a city could be any city in the world
but uh that's uh very nice look nice
perch that he had there